foreign
[Music]
hi guys it's Quinn here if you
appreciate my content consider hitting
the like button it's the only way the
YouTube algorithm notices me
if you'd like to do more to keep this
channel afloat consider donating through
the PayPal Link in the description or
checking out our patreon thanks guys so
much
so I'm currently working on a long form
video on a topic that I know you guys
are going to enjoy a lot but I also
wanted to take some time to go back to
one of my all-time favorite sci-fi book
series Dune and cover a topic that's a
little bit obscure to most people now
this is an aspect of the series that I
find endlessly fascinating
in the book Dune towards the end Paula
trades says to his mother Jessica
I am the fulcrum
now what does this mean imagine that the
universe is a wooden board a seesaw
at either end of that wooden board are
two possible paths for the universe
Paul Atreides would be
the center supporting it all the lever
by which the universe itself turns
because he became the quizets had Iraq
granting him the ability to see the
possible Futures he became the fulcrum
by which the fate of the universe itself
moves by simply acting he decides the
fate of everything so before I go any
further I just want to remind you that
this video will have spoilers for The
Dune Saga in the first dune book Paul is
seeing visions of a terrible Jihad the
legions of Freeman spreading out Across
the Universe in his name killing
billions of citizens of the universe
this happens Paul lives through it all
in his name and then we get to Dune
Messiah
in Dune Messiah it is revealed that far
darker things are to come still
and it implies that these things are set
in motion by Paul's own actions
he remembered his earliest divisions of
the Jihad to be
the terror and Revolution he'd
experienced now of course he knew
visions of Greater terrors
he had lived with the real violence he
had seen his Freeman charged with
mystical strength sweep all before them
in the religious War
the Jihad gained A New Perspective it
was finite of course a brief spasm when
measured against eternity
but beyond Les Horus to overshadow
anything in the past
all in my name Paul thought
now let's Jump Ahead a little bit we all
know about the God Emperor Leto II
Paul's son who would undergo a several
thousand years long transformation into
the worm God emperor in order to save
Humanity from a great threat
now what many people Miss is that Paul
also foresaw this threat and considered
becoming the worm God Emperor himself
and Doon Messiah when Paul lays Eyes
Upon Duncan Idaho's clone he begins to
have visions of a possible future
involving a Gola of Duncan Idaho
the book says old Visions surged around
Paul would he have to choose that
terrible way distorted time hinted at
this Gola in That Hideous future would
that way close in upon him no matter
what he did
now as you may know the god Emperor had
Duncan Idaho made into a Gola over and
over and over and over again for
thousands of years Duncan is obviously a
key component to the god Emperor's
design and actually in Chapter House
demon and Heretics of Dune the Benny
Jesuit are trying to figure out why the
god Emperor was so interested in Duck in
Idaho and they begin to make goldless of
him themselves but of course Paul was
very very terrified of the idea of
becoming the god Emperor because of what
it entails you have to give up your
Humanity thousands of years of
loneliness with the weight of all
mankind on your shoulders it's no wonder
that Paul ultimately runs from this
Prospect at the end of Dune Messiah
leaving his son leito II to inherit that
burden and take on this great enemy this
great threat as the god emperor so now
let's talk about this great threat now
I've talked about this in multiple
videos you can check out my video on
Cruella Zack if you want me to go into
significant detail about it basically
later II and Paul the trades had
foreseen a tremendous threat that would
lead to the near destruction or complete
destruction of all of humankind it's
implied in God emperor of Dune that this
threat would arrive from Human design
specifically ixian design the ixians of
course were technological innovators on
the outskirts of the universe that
constantly kind of pushed the limits of
the butlerian Jihad it's implied that
they were making machines that at the
very least resembled the human mind that
was to say they resembled Computing
devices which is against one of the main
tenets of the butler in Jihad Thou shalt
not make a machine in the likeness of a
human mind so we get hints in God in
emperor of Dune that the ixians are
already kind of pushing it and then
finally it is completely confirmed that
the ixians are in fact defying the
butlerian Jihad and the god Emperor is
buying from them interestingly enough
he's not stopping them he's letting it
happen now why is he letting it happen
because he can't simply remove the
threat but he can prepare a Humanity for
the threat and that's exactly what he's
doing
now let's talk about the nature of the
threat
the book says
the seeking machines would be there the
smell of blood and entrails the cowering
humans in their Burrows aware only that
they could not Escape
while all the time the mechanical
movement approached nearer and nearer
louder louder
everywhere she searched it would be the
same No Escape anywhere he felt her life
ebbing fight the darkness siona that was
one thing the Atreides did they fought
for life and now she was fighting for
lives other than her own
so a few things are revealed to us here
the seeking machines this is clearly a
reference to Hunter Seeker devices which
have been appearing since the first dune
book Hunter's secret devices are
programmed with a specific prey in mind
and they hunt and seek and kill the
target the implication here is that
something went quite wrong with a
particular ixian Hunter Seeker model
let's say this model got out of hand and
it was a little too good at hunting and
seeking humans it was perhaps so good
so intelligent that it manifested a kind
of prescience
it was an oracle it could predict the
future it could seek out humans no
matter how well they hid and as dune
Messiah mentions the only thing that can
Shield something from an oracle is
another Oracle so essentially if
everyone had the power of the quiz
atarak or at least some rudimentary form
of crescience like the guild Navigators
possess they could Shield themselves
from these prescient Hunter Seeker
devices but Leto also saw the danger in
prescience and prescience wasn't
something that he wanted to spread to
all of humanity so instead he created a
new Gene a no Gene a gene that gave
anyone that possessed it the ability to
hide from prescience they could not be
seen by the prescient eye that is what
siona was and as long as siona spread
her genes throughout Humanity ultimately
humans
in the long run would be fine that's why
leito is allowing the ixians to continue
their work he says at the end of God
emperor of Dune do not fear the ixians
they can make the machines but they can
no longer make arafel I know I was there
we've discussed what rfl means in other
videos it's essentially a reference to
the Bible
Psalm 97 verses 1 through 3 the Lord
reineth let the Earth Rejoice let the
multitude of Isles be glad thereof
clowns and darkness are round about him
righteousness and judgment are the
habitation of his throne
essentially leito is saying the ixians
cannot make the final judge of humanity
they cannot make God do not fear the
ixians now as I said it's arguable that
Paul set these things in motion but I
think it also can be argued that
something like the ixians going too far
with their technology might have been
inevitable but regardless Paul chose not
to act to save Humanity he couldn't bear
the weight the responsibility of the
horrors that that were ahead of him and
make no mistake even when later II
becomes the god Emperor Humanity still
suffers a lot and he says that Humanity
will continue to suffer survival is
painful lato has saved humanity and yet
a very dark future still lies ahead of
them and yet
it is not the darkest possible future
there's a darker future that was waiting
for Humanity if lato had never stepped
in in the book God emperor of Dune leito
has this conversation with siona
what makes you do what you do
the question was well framed he said my
need to save people
what people my definition is much
broader than that of anyone else even of
the bini Jesuit who think they have
defined what it is to be human I refer
to the Eternal thread of all humankind
by whatever definition
you're trying to tell me
her mouth became too dry for speaking
she tried to accumulate saliva he saw
the movements within her face mask her
question was obvious though and he did
not wait
without me there would have been by now
no people anywhere none whatsoever
and the path to that Extinction was more
hideous than your wildest imaginings
it's not clear if this destruction of
humanity would have been the result of
an early version of the ixian rfl that
later slowed down or if Humanity would
have met its destruction by other means
what is clear is that for all the
tyranny of lato's rule all the Death
that would come following his Reign
during the famine times and the
scattering for the sake of the golden
path was actually necessary if survival
is the goal of humanity Paul would have
left Humanity to fend for itself in the
chaos live or die I personally think
that what later II did was pretty noble
to save all of humanity to be the hero
he had to become the villain the
greatest villain that ever lived the
duneside is always endlessly fascinating
if you've enjoyed this video make sure
you like this video And subscribe for
more content and don't forget to check
out my new podcast Cosmic Chronicles if
you enjoy long form content Link in the
description thanks so much for watching
as I said you can check out our patreon
if you would like to support this
Channel or use the PayPal Link in the
description thanks guys
[Music]